In this video we present a set of
studies that led us to establish the
Uncanny Valley of Haptics theory.
The Uncanny Valley was first used to
describe a visually triggered revulsion to
the hyper-realistic
avatars that were almost but not quite
perfectly human.
Now we show that a similar effect
can be observed for our sense of touch.
We generate an illusion of
spacial touch inside virtual reality
by providing synchronous vibrations of
different amplitudes to two handheld controllers.
The hands are also connected in the
virtual environment by a wooden dowel.
We then show a small white marble
that seems to knock on the dowel at
different locations as we vary the
vibratory sensations. The touches are
felt to be located in the empty space
between the hands. When we produce the
same stimulation without the marble the
apparent out-of-the-body spatial
location of the touch sensations will
persist. However, where improvements in
the spatialization of touch created a
worse subjective experience than a
generic vibration of equal amplitude to
both hands, the experience was improved
when the participants moved the virtual
dowel up and down; thereby making them
the agent of the tactile sensations.
In this paper we show for the first time
that improvements in haptics might fall
into an uncanny valley, and we delineate key
features to avoid this Uncanny Valley of Haptics.